morning and he knew that Ian Duncan
Smith was going to be your biggest ally
in all of this I don't think he and
Duncan Smith is an ally at all in Duncan
Smith has presided over the most
terrible treatment of people with
disabilities and the most vulnerable in
our society he's finally found a
conscience and resigned and his
successor is now looking for exactly the
same level of cuts from somewhere else
within that budget this is a budget that
doesn't add up it's unraveled and I
think it's George Osborne who should be
appearing before the Commons and
explaining exactly what his budget now
is what we're not hearing from the
Chancellor we not heard from him all
weekend was certainly not hearing from
him this morning his credibility his
position is being questioned do you
think he should resign as Chancellor
indeed I think he has to consider his
position because he's put forward a
budget that was predicated on four
billion cuts to personal independence
payments over this Parliament so at the
same time proposed tax cuts at the other
end of the scale on corporation tax and
capital gains tax it's not a credible
budget it simply doesn't add up
I really fail to see how Parliament
could possibly improve it and we are
going to be hearing from the prime
minister at around 3:30 this morning
Prime Minister's Questions what do you
want to hear from him and what are you
going to be putting to him over all of
this well I understand the Prime
Minister's statement that he's due to
make to partners after news can after
the EU council on the refugee crisis and
the way in which Turkey and Greece being
treated and have to act within this but
I think he should actually be making a
statement about the budget and about the
way his government is operating and so
I've no doubt that these issues are
going to be raised as well within
Parliament today well the government
have gone from promoting the budgets are
now defending it today they do seem to
be fighting fires on all fronts not just
on this issue of disability benefits but
also on the sugar tax as well we're
hearing that big companies may plan to
sue them over this what are their climb
downs would you like to see from them
because let's face it they're going to
be making another embarrassing you turn
in a second year when it comes to the
budget well they haven't made a total
u-turn on personal independence payments
yes they announced it in the budget a
day later they said it was actually
consultation not a proposal and then a
couple of days after that the news
country says it's not going to be
preceded with but they're looking for in
their words savings elsewhere in that
budget so it's not a complete climb down
what I want to see is a protection of
the DWP budget a protection of the
payments for those with disabilities in
our society because that is the heart of
it how do we treat people in our society
do we have tax breaks at the one end for
those that can well afford to continue
paying the current or even in Harts
rates of tax and we then hit those who
want to live independently and
contribute to society whatever their
disability is it's a basically an issue
about justice you say that but the
government would argue that they have
been squeezing money out of
middle-income earners and the Hiab and
rate of taxpayers as well so the money
is coming from them as well well
everybody does pay tax or should all
corporations GP rate of tax they would
say that they have made made roads to
get more money out of those groups of
society well they've actually lowered
the rate of Taxation at the top end of
the scale that seems to me to be wholly
wrong when the same time you're cutting
disability budgets surely the priority
ought to be to say well whatever the
circumstances those that need help and
support through a decent society such as
personal independence payments should
have them protected and guaranteed it
seems to me there's a sort of lurking
wolf there in the DWP that's going
around saying how can we get more money
off those who probably need it the very
most Saliba would protect the DWP budget
as a whole there is a big black hole in
the finances now if this is scrapped
how would Labor Philip we would promote
an expanding economy will you promote
greater levels of capital investment in
our economy to encourage economic growth
so that instead of an austerity program
we would actually be promoting a growing
economy obviously more people in work on
better wages pay more tax than a lot of
people out of work on low wages that
surely is the right direction to go what
we've had is six years of austerity when
they said it would all be over in 5 ozz
one is now saying
even me over by 2020 is now looking at
20 21 22 23
whatever the five-year plan is with
Osborne it's always five years away
okay well all that is going to play out
in the Commons later on this afternoon I
just want to bring up an issue that's
dogging your party at the moment and
this anti semitism rail that seems to be
gathering pace particular over the last
few days allegations of anti-semitism
within labour party ranks now speaking
out yesterday the Labour peer Lord levy
said he would quit the party unless you
deliver a category and specific
condemnation of anti-semitism Lord levy
clearly hasn't been listening to the
seven times since I became leader I've
absolutely condemned anti-semitism I've
condemned Islamophobia I've condemned
any form of racism anywhere within our
society it is absolutely something I
totally passionately believe in and I'm
disappointed that Lord levy has made
these remarks he knows full well what my
views are he knows full well what the
views of the Labour Party are he knows
full well the kind of decent inclusive
society that we all want to live in I
look forward to having that discussion
with him if there is anybody behaving
badly anywhere in society any kind of
racism in has to be dealt with it has to
be investigated I had a long meeting
with a group of women in my constituency
Muslim women who told me the levels of
abuse they receive on the buses and
trains Transport for London are dealing
with that because I've asked them to
exactly the same applies to anybody else
Jewish women or Jewish men if they're
abused on the street deserve exactly the
same protection as everybody else we
have to recognize we are a multi-faith
multicultural multi-ethnic society and
behave with decency and respect and
inclusivity towards everyone and that is
exactly what I'm doing as leader of the
party that's exactly what the Labour
Party stands for we're the party that
introduced the first race relations act
we're the party that introduced the
Human Rights Act we're the party they
introduced the equalities act we're the
party that stands up for that decent
inclusive society that we all want to
live in but mr. Cole when you find
yourself having to state that here on
Sky News this morning why isn't
message getting through why is one of
your labor peers having to ask that
question you have got internal
investigations going on within the Labor
Party as to some of your members I use
the example of Vicki Kirby it was
excluded from the party over
anti-semitism then including the party
then excluded again them back in why
isn't this trickling through the Labour
Party ranks it is very much through the
labour party ranks it's something that's
fully understood throughout the labour
party fully understood and we do take
action on the very very very small
number of cases where anything happens
and if we hear any allegations they are
properly and thoroughly investigated
this is a party that stands up for all
the things that we as a society
absolutely believe in and if there are
complaints of anybody has then they will
be investigated as they are being
investigated at the present time but the
idea that somehow or other there's a
tolerance of any form of racism is
wholly and totally fallacious okay
Jeremy Corbyn labour leader thank you
for speaking to us here on Sky News
sunrise